now we're in trouble there for a second
but it's fun we're fine
[Music]
han Solo do ya was yours your hair or a
wig my hair um thanks wow did that act
is sort of like a Samson esque
experience just giving you strength
wherever you went sure yeah I guess you
could put it like that that's yeah yeah
yeah it was a whole you know wanting it
to feel like this or that yeah it was
good hell yeah in the entire world of
sci-fi who would you want to be your
co-pilot I gotta say I know because
that's the that's really the bread and
butter I mean that's really who you want
to fly with and especially as Han you
know like they just complement each
other in that way can you tell me a
little bit about how you filmed all
those stunts because you are getting
tossed around a lot yeah we had some
wires and then I had a great stunt guy
Luke who did a lot of stuff but we were
in there and we were in there for three
weeks and it was the first thing we shot
oh yeah it was pretty wild
did you get a lot of dirt in your mouth
a tremendous amount of dirt and mud and
everything else and there's also what
you don't see is the 40 people who were
making the movie they're all in the mud
pit with you covered in mud constantly
all day long right trying to wash it out
of their hair I mean that's how we all
started with this yeah and then you're
like wow there's literally places I was
not expecting that places you didn't
even know you had yeah do you prefer
your Millennium Falcon cleaner dirty
dirty when you first walked into that
bad boy yeah and I read like that this
is the biggest version that that has
ever been built I know that it's the the
inside of it is the I think the first
time it's been you know there's a shot
where you go up the ramp and through
in a way I don't think they've done
before take me back to that moment man
like when you first approached this
monster I walked into it when I was
doing my audition I had my third
audition on it with Chewie and it was
wild and you kind of get on it it's very
familiar and there's the hollow chest
table and the thing and it was the
hallway it was very very fun when you're
sitting in the cockpit and you're
looking out what do you actually see
this is one of the things that was
really shocking surprising so if this is
the cockpit in front of the it is a
screen that is projecting kind of like
old movies someone's driving a car and
then project the thing the background
they would project everything we're
flying through in front of us so we're
looking at all of that and fly seeing
everything we're flying around and I
mean it's really quite incredible and
really puts you in the feeling of it's
like the ultimate Disneyland ride it's
awesome and like when you hit warp speed
you see that you every time we would you
know do that and it would go mmm and
we're there it was so great who would
you want to be your co-pilot well I'm
pretty won over by l3 space she is so
smart and you know I mean and she's
entertaining yeah so that's a great
combination
Chuy's a little hard for me to
understand he's got chops he's got
skills but a little hard for me to
follow yeah I can i I can really connect
with l3 listen I had enough trouble with
French in high school for me but l3 she
is so deeply cranky yes I was really
taken by her because I was like this
robot is real
she's so real yeah yeah and yeah but but
you gotta love her I do
if there was any other movie that you
could relate this experience to of yours
that you've directed which one does it
kind of evoke well we'll owe a lot
similar challenge of creating a you know
a universe visual effects you know heart
but also humor but this one I love the
plot twists and I like the way the
character relationships worked so
there's there's even more dimension of
course than in Willow I liked how
unpredictable the relationships were the
action scenes and the way it all worked
to define Han Solo this journey this
rite of passage that he was going on as
a director that really gave me something
interesting to focus on but it meant
every scene and moments within scenes
kept shifting I had a blast with all
that I was really excited for Ron Howard
to do heist movie just exactly what this
is I was like dude like imagine somebody
asked me like how was the premiere is it
good and I was like I don't know bro
imagine if it was like Parenthood but
Steve Martin stole stuff well thank you
thank you
the crime heist component it makes so
much sense when you realize what he's
gonna become a smuggler yeah and as a
defining adventure and yet you wouldn't
necessarily think of it and that's what
I loved about the script when I read it
because it answers a lot of the
questions that you might have about Han
Solo what what you know what might have
shaped him but it does it in surprising
ways
so it's satisfying it's logical but it's
not exactly what you would have expected
and I thought that was kind of what was
brilliant about the story in the script
and for me sitting in my seat it was
deeply satisfying too because I wasn't
expecting the things that I saw good and
I was like oh cool that's answered thank
you that's exactly what the Kazan's were
going for and which I and and and the
one thing that I tried to do as a
director staging the scenes shaping
performances and and and and then in the
editing was to always keep making
everything be about Han so the whether
it's a whether it's an action scene
whether it's a funny scene or something
very serious or a twist and a turn it's
all about what
this mean - hon how's it testing him how
could this potentially shape him as he
becomes that iconic character that we're
going to know about later but the other
thing is to keep it pure so that you
don't have to know anything to really be
able to get into this story and go on
this adventure with the characters weird
that every time that you're saying
something I'm just imagining a star
wars-themed Arrested Development episode
no no no I like that that's sort of the
diversity of my dimension of my career
appreciate that very flattering I heard
a story about you I was wondering if
it's true everything right about me it's
true
l-3 let's go with a mean man's face
these guys
who would you want to be your copilot
out of all sci-fi and this is such a
easy answer I mean me I mean it it's I
mean not an easy it's easy but I mean
like it's cheesy because it's I just
wouldn't want to be with anybody okay
it's the only way I'd be resenting
anyone else yeah I've had so much fun in
the cockpit with her like I really we
really did here's what really stood out
about l-3 she's super duper cranky well
they they do treat her crapoly yeah like
about the universe like kind of thing
it's like they don't even serve our kind
yeah I'm like I love that line cuz it's
a reference but it's also like yeah I'd
probably want to crush somebody's face
if they didn't serve me yeah yeah she
doesn't pay respects to anyone who
doesn't deserve it but that's kinda
what's refreshing about her yeah she's
just like get out did you feel yourself
getting kind of like in that cranky
groove onthis even we weren't shooting
all I wanted to do was just do like
weird dance moves in the in the in the
suit because it was just too good I mean
I found myself doing it alone in a
corridor felt so good so the crankiness
probably didn't bleed through into into
into real life but there was definitely
that arc of her feeling she's being a
bit bolshy improve you know I know you'd
have to ask yeah I was cranky no I mean
especially for what they put her through
like there was so much on her like all
the time like anytime like it's like
gets hot so there's like blowing air at
people's face and then like you have to
put this on and you have to use the belt
I'm like I didn't have to I just had to
move a cape out of the way if I want to
use a bouncer
it's exhausting but important question
how many capes is too many capes at the
right tents out of all of the whole
sci-fi universe who would you want to be
your co-pilot I mean Chewie you know
what I mean classic he's on my boobs for
a reason Emilia Clarke exactly wait a
second out of the whole what sci-fi
universe or I can go anywhere anyway so
I could take Scarlet Witch
hell yeah you could well I'm on a solo
presto Disney umbrella here's the way I
can get down with Dryden boss because he
is a post murder Rose a kind of guy
which I'm into yeah totally and I would
like to know about his makeup as
compared to what you go through for
vision there was no process there's the
stuff and this was all CG it's not even
real the whole thing whole thing and it
changed his coloring guys really dark
when I get angry so yeah they they they
they they did all of that post
do you ever drop an accidental spoiler
just when you're feeling really casual
sometimes you forget where you are who
you talking to
how much alcohol you've drunk but it
depends because I'm not gonna lie my
very close friends are gonna be very
into this but I've been on Game of
Thrones for a little while now and
they're like yeah we know do you know
what I mean right
they're totally I'm really interested in
like what what we're talking about on
whatsapp rather than so that sort of
thing but if I'm dropping it in
conversation with a journalist that's
when you're in trouble
sure sure you know grain yeah but your
friends are just over it they're like I
don't get it you're amazing they're
dragons it's it's done yeah and now you
have blasters and every and you're
awesome and like let's move on and talk
about laundry well pretty much yeah yeah
I get it yeah I am so taken by the
Millennium Falcon and it's the first
time that you
I've ever seen outside - inside of the
Millennium Falcon we have a shot that
takes you from outside the Menem fog on
to inside the Millennium Falcon it's a
very big deal and you did that in real
life walked in her life to the inside
inside you didn't how bummed out are you
about that or did you wait a cameras
move oh no I did yeah and I did I did I
was like a tour guide I was every friend
the in London brought their children to
set come on the Millennium Falcon yeah
are you kidding
if you come with us you're in this life
for good
the real challenge has been how in the
hell do we even ask questions about this
without ruining it I know I feel like
we're all here together to celebrate
love for Star Wars for the whole
franchise it's so comforting because
it's something familiar but we also know
we're gonna be surprised by something
new and exciting and you also know that
everybody involved has done their
damnedest to bring you the best of what
movies can bring so I want to expand
this to you can pick anybody from the
whole sci-fi universe to be your
co-pilot well in a way you would almost
have to be Han because he's the greatest
pilot is he gonna have the copilot you
want it to be the best pilot I might
think of a different one tomorrow but
the first one I thought about was the
blue the blue lady in Avatar
I love bright Nefertari her name yes I
want her I loved her how big she is
compared to human beings you know when
they when they actually saw each other
finally they're like she's quite big I
want her in my car or whatever vehicle
is oh my god is it you see if I don't
know but you don't be an HOV Lane no cop
would ever pull you over with no
obviously we have the roof back she's
big so a little a big blue had to be out
that and I'd just be like loving on her
you two are so your characters are so
well matched in this movie and I felt
like this amazing harmony imbalance
nice yeah including in the you know
losses and gains of what they go through
yes you know it's no you know yeah I
mean he goes to big ego is that the
other thing there are a couple there
like that they're kind of like an old
married couple like I love how they
argue with each other as well as like
you said it's then really uncool you
also know that they love each other but
that's kind of it adds to how they love
each other the fact that they can have
you know arguments on screen like this
one and off I sense there's gonna be
when the minute I walk out of this
well what do you know I was thinking
about how cool it is to see Chewie
throwing dudes everywhere
it was the most marvellous thing to
actually get to [ __ ] I was looking
forward to those scenes and because the
script was awesome and the adventure
very varied and surprising unexpected
and and to get to see that side of chewy
a little bit it's gonna be great to see
how everyone is going to take it oh
they're gonna flip out
yeah definitely the response can you
take me behind the scenes a little bit
and tell me how when you are throwing a
poor suspecting movie character but
who's really a professional up against
the ceiling like are they on wires
what's happening there I think yeah it's
ownable
it's a wire gag and they're there but
you also gotta bring it you got to do it
because if you don't if you don't go
through them the motion and really jerk
him up it's not gonna look look real and
we would did a couple of takes of that
one it was unbelievable to see because
we really I think we got the we got the
perfect taking them for the movie well
you totally sore the next day and then
you're just like dude yesterday has
thrown dudes against the ceiling like oh
we didn't take it we didn't need dad
mate thanks for that but whatever yeah
oh you're always sore when you're
playing Chewbacca because he's always
out and about doing different stuff this
one's super physical too yeah yeah so
now if you could pick any character from
all of sci-fi who would you want to be
your co-pilot I think I would have
Luke's copilot for my part Strikes Back
dak oh nice oh good because he's yeah
cuz he would take on the whole empire
himself so I could just let him take on
the Empire while I sip on a cocktail or
something
[Music]
[Music]